East assaulted IndyCar Chester Sasha
kaun up will be test driving what he
calls the legitimate successor to the
legendary 205 GTI the Peugeot 208 GTI
he says the GTI delighted drivers twenty
years ago now he'll see what the new one
can do with the new 208 GTI who Joe is
hoping to build on it's well-founded
success the basic model is the regular
208 a fun little car that's been on the
market now for over a year the changes
start with a chassis the 208 GTI is
front axle make for more accurate
steering especially at high speeds
ssangshik Knapp is familiar with the GTI
engine from the Pujo RCZ which was a
product of a cooperation with BMW
veganism the 208 GTI differs from the
regular 208 in design as well with
compact dimensions and a promise of
ample sportiness as with a sylvestris
ancestor the 208 GTI has a wider toe
than the regular 208 by one centimeter
in back and two in front the rear
spoiler and diffusers stressed the GTI
sporting ambitions sascha points out to
the GTI is 147 kilowatts alene powered
engine is 15 kilowatts stronger than the
VW polos GT is it'll go from 0 to 100
km/h in 6.8 seconds topping out at 230
speeds lag then of course the co2
emissions not so green the 208 GTI has
plenty of cargo space for its size at
least enough to accommodate one or two
suitcases
sasha says the interior is also sporty
and stylish especially likes the colored
plastic trim the same colors show up in
the door handles to a nice detail is the
aluminum pedal pads the dashboard is
covered with imitation leather a touch
of luxury in the Puzo's all-round sporty
feel sasha lists the peugeot 208 GTI
rivals the VW Polo GTI the Opel Corsa
OPC is it 20 s3 and its racing version
and there are no Clio RS in terms of
technical data the Peugeot 208 GTI has
little to fear from its competition even
if its fuel consumption bring it at 5.9
litres per 100 kilometers is a bit
optimistic after all a GTI is meant to
be driven like a sports car in terms of
performance the Peugeot 208 GTI has a
lot to offer and starting at 22,000 900
euros in Germany it's the best priced
car of its kind Sasha says going a 180
kilometers an hour the wind is so loud
that it really bothers him even so his
general impression is a positive one all
the specs are in order and the price is
right
you